all right tanisha we're gonna start with
two from you so you can um
start it off okay we're gonna start
one moment sorry everybody
big show t-shirt i know arch wow
all right all right tanisha go ahead
all right we're gonna stay off with dave
yeah hey anthony um i'm uh somewhere in
the arena i don't know where you are
right now but um
i wanted you to just walk us through the
final sequences
uh where you guys were able to pull that
out and did it feel like
an nba basketball game even though no
fans and obviously this different arena
uh we want to make sure that they got a
two-point
[ __ ] out of three and somehow paul
got over we'll look at it on film
um omega-3 but we want to make sure that
we come out execute on the offensive
it felt like a real game to me you know
two teams battling
obviously it's always a good game
between us two plus two teams and
you know the more and more that we the
use of this arena
the more easier it will be but um
melissa
katie um so even in a game with no fans
and considering
that you know the stakes were uh
comparatively low it seemed
like the intensity was just as high as
if it were
you know a huge game in front of 20 000
fans is that how it felt
they did a great job with the crown
noise you know especially when we
scored the parkour got to stop got
pretty loud also at timeouts
so they did a good job with that but
like i said when we're out there
competing you know we just worry about
the the fog
on the floor and trying
what were your emotions like uh before
the game
broadcast um obviously it's a
sensitive subject i mean uh you know we
want to make sure that we did
you know something that's a league um
the mbpa
and the nba and all the players you know
just
kind of consisted that you know mailing
was best um something that we can do as
a league and be unified and um
we go ahead and play you know not for us
but
for everything that's going around going
on around the world
for them i didn't know they were going
to have a video up there so
i think that was pretty cool you know
i'm not sure they might look for every
game but
i think that was really cool to kind of
play that video and um just kind of
remind us
what's going on in the world because
we're so locked into this bubble you
know
on social media so um for for both teams
to come together
um the head coaches kind of switch uh
and us locking up together in front of
the black lives matter
[Music]
um
uh we came out kind of slow they were
getting a lot of open shots
and we were following we want to fight
any defense
and we couldn't make shots we had a
couple bad shots
uh some open shots that we usually make
and we just kind of stayed with it we
knew they're gonna make a run you know
they made everyone got up eleven we just
wanna make sure that we just kept
playing
uh pick it up defensively and we're able
to do that you know and then we started
making shots on the office today kind of
gave us the actual
extra boost that we needed going to the
fourth and
it was a game all the way to the end so
i just wanted to make sure that they
didn't
run away with it they definitely have a
chance
all right hey anthony it's mike trudell
back in los angeles uh
just wonder what you thought of some of
those second unit groupings when caruso
and waders and who's right there with
you
and if there's anything that you focus
on in those small mall groups
specifically
gotta run anytime we gotta stop you know
we want to run
you know whether i'm pushing cools ac
um and then still trying to implement
you know dion and jr
into the system i think for the most
part we played well we played well as a
unit
we had our moments on defense where we
could play better but for the most part
we were able to you know execute our
schemes
especially but
i say that that's extremely well ac
played
played well down the end making some big
[ __ ] scores
and cools make some big shots so you
know god's really getting back in school
hey anthony you guys are now two and two
again
uh the clippers frank said before the
game that you guys will probably
run into each other again before this is
all said and done i'm just wondering at
this point after you've gone through
this season series
you feel like these are the two teams in
the west do you feel like that's the
only team that will stand between you
guys in the finals
i'm worried about once again that's the
lakers uh we can't control what other
teams do
and how they play or what they're going
to do so we only get trouble we can
control and that's how we play and um
two questions kyle uh maybe after
uh you guys played this game in march
you described this as
a series that you would like because it
was physical
it was pretty you it still feel that way
tonight did it feel
a lot different a little different about
the science um i'm still going to have
you know two guys who really
helped them out on their second unit and
montreal
they've got other guys didn't come in
and play
but it still felt like a game back in
staples
or physical it was created guys who are
getting after
compete on both ends of the floor both
teams
and that's what makes plant planning so
fun and last question mark medina
and there are so many different elements
with different runs the whistles
what does it take to just get through
all these different
frustrations oh the reps hear everything
we say now so
that's kind of new for some kind of kind
of
kind of a little bit but um
i think we just you know for us
especially we just gotta
you know keep playing can't worry about
you know calls and everything like that
um unless we try to complain to the rest
and we'll argue a call
uh the better we'll be and there's
everyone
but i say it was it was a good first
game for us you know i think
you know we played extremely well both
on the floor um
atmosphere is a little different but i
think as the game goes on you can adjust
it to it
and you're locked into it was going over
the floor or not
you know more so what's what's going on
you know outside of the floor
um but as far as the in-game thing that
i think we're supposed to talk about
all right thanks so much anthony thank
you japanese